- So, well, today is
dedicated to rock and roll.
And we've asked Jon Bon Jovi earlier,
what defines rock music for you?
- Well to me, rock and roll
has always been the music
that we aren't supposed to
listen to as youth, you know.
It was,
it started with being, you know,
it's very sexual in nature.
It's about the taboos
and it's about breaking the social norms.
And it's as if you watch how a
rock and roll sort of changed
over time, and we sort
of changed over time,
now, I consider your hip hop and rap
sort of rock and roll now
because it's the music
that you don't want your
kids to listen to, you know?
- (laughs) Yeah.
So you, you're such a mom.
So who were your musical
inspirations growing up?
Who were people you weren't
supposed to listen to
and you wanted to become? (laughs)
- Right. (laughs)
Well, Bruce Springs, you
know, Bruce Springsteen was,
he just seemed to have the answers for me,
as far as rock and roll,
you know, was going.
I probably ended up somewhere
between Janis Joplin
and Bruce Springsteen, you know? (laughs)
- Oh my god, I remember that time,
I think it was on the Grammys,
and you covered "A Piece Of My Heart".
Holy moly.
I was like, so I kind of wanted to quit,
'cause I was like, (laughs) well,
I'm never gonna do anything like that.
Like, it was just, it was amazing.
And it, it just was one of
those times I feel like when,
we all love singing,
we all love performing,
but there's times when like
you don't even remember what happened
and you become the vessel
for something so much
bigger than yourself.
And that just felt like
that to me watching it.
- It was a very healing moment for me.
I was bald from chemotherapy.
I had gone through that and
it was my first time on stage,
or even in front of people.
I hadn't even been in crowds.
I was still doing radiation treatments.
And it meant a lot to me
to get up, and it was,
it was a big changing moment in my life.
It's kind of before that Grammys and after
is kinda my musical career. (laughs)
- Yeah.
- And yeah, that was,
that was one of my top five moments ever.
- Oh my god. Well, that's
so funny 'cause literally,
we have shared the stage
before and I was freaking out,
putting my best Meryl Streep on,
acting like I was like totally fine.
- Yeah.
Oh, it's so sweet.
And it's very important to me as,
as I've gone through this, my career,
to really reach out to the
women who are coming up
and making a name and you were just,
you were just hitting your stride.
You were really doing great.
And you know, you also hold
that sort of rock and roll torch,
but also you're just a
down to earth person.
- Ah, thank you.
That means a lot coming from you.